Madame Mademoiselle Monsieur bonsoir
personne ne veut donc accueillir
l'ex-empereur bookasa le règne de
l'empereur qui avait commencé dans une
incroyable magnificence se termine dans
le dérisoire bookasa 1ier est sans doute
dernier empereur de centraafrique est
toujours à l'intérieur de sa Caravel sur
l'aéroport militaire d'Évreux mais cette
situation qui se prolonge provoque des
réactions l'Association française des
juristes démocrates s'étonne que l'on
puisse refuser l'accès du territoire
français à bokasa qui a aussi la
citoyenneté française il faut donc
arrêter l'ex-empereur Bokassa et le
juger pour les crimes qu'il a commis
affirme cette association de juristes et
à l'instant je reçoit la réaction de
François mitteran Premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste quand je pense dit
François mitteran que d'heure en heure
depuis 48h on nous entretient du sort de
cet empereur de comédie qui n'a dû son
pouvoir qu'à la complaisance des
pouvoirs publics français quand je pense
à cette sordide négociation qui veut
qu'aujourd'hui tous les regards soient
tournés vers celui qui massacra les
enfants de ses compatriotes mais qui fut
mais qui fut pendant si longtemps
considéré comme un pilier de la présence
française en Afrique et l'amis personnel
de nos dirigeants je pense dit François
mitteran que le décalage est sensible
entre la grande ambition de notre
République sa mission à travers la
planète et l'image qu'on en donne
aujourd'hui sur place en République
centrafricaine plusieurs centaines
d'étudiants sont descendus dans la rue
pour protester contre le maintien des
ministres et des responsables militaires
sousbokasa tandis que le gouvernement
tchadien adressé aujourd'hui à Paris la
protestation la plus énergique le
gouvernement tchadien proteste en effet
contre l'envoi en République
centrafricaine de troupes françaises
basées au Tchad sans que le gouvernement
tchadien nit eu son mot à dire monsieur
daakco le nouveau président de la
République centrafricaine s'est en tout
cas félicité du soutien de la France et
de la présence des soldats français qui
ont permis a-t-il dit un coup d'État
sans effusion de sang Alain d'ver ils
sont 500 maintenant les soldats français
qui contrôle l'aéroport la présidence la
centrale électrique qui patrouille qui
vérifie les identités et qui évite le
renouvellement des pillages du premier
jour présence française massive donc qui
jusqu'à présent tout au moins semble
rassurer la population ces contrôles
selon David daakco ont permis d'arrêter
37 libiens tous armés et disposant de
plusieurs caches d'armes dans la ville
quant aux 900 hommes de la garde
personnelle de l'empereur les seuls
soldats centrafricains armés la présence
des professionnels français les ont
dissuadé d'un Barau d'honneur ils sont
presque tous ralliés en revanche 2000
étudiants et universita sont descendus
dans la rue ce matin ce qui a créé une
certaine tension d'abord ils ont
déboulonné une immense statue de bokasa
il l'ont ramené comme un trophée dans
les quartiers africains mais surtout ils
ont demandé au président d'ako de se
débarrasser du personnel politique de
l'ex-empereur rester en bloc dans ses
fonctions cible essentielle des
manifestants l'ancien Premier ministre
Henri maidou devenu vice-présidente de
la République meou qui était présent
lors de la conférence de presse au cours
de laquelle
a demandé à Monsieur de s'expliquer sur
l'intervention française nous ferons
appel au pays amis d'Afrique comme
d'Europe pour nous aider à assurer au
peuple centrafricain la
sécurité et cette aide nous l'avons déjà
obtenu de plusieurs pays
africainsavons également obtenu du
premier pays européens qui nous assiste
depuis 70 ans je cite la France
et c'est pour cela
que tant que nous n'aurons pas assuré au
peuple la sécurité
totale nous ferons toujours appel à
cette assistance technique à cette
assistance
militaire l'empereur bookassa est donc
toujours à l'intérieur de sa caravelle
sur la base 105 d'Évreux paradoxe de
l'histoire la fin du règne se termine là
où il avait pratiquement commencé c'est
en effet en Normandie tout près
d'hévreux que furent conçus les fastes
du couronnement impérial du 4 cemb 77
l'escorte d'honneur et le dressage des
chevaux du carrosse impérial avaient en
effet été réalisé en Normandie
maintenant ce sont les Normands qui se
sont déplacés vers la base aérienne
devenu but de promenade du dimanche sur
place l'un des envoyés spéciaux de TF1
Jacques
collet longue fastidieuse et
infructueuse attente tout au long de ce
dimanche aux abord de la base aérienne
d'evrefauville devant le mutisme complet
des autorités on en est une fois de plus
réduit aux hypothèses ainsi par exemple
ce balai de voiture noire aperçu cet
après-midi aux abords de la Caravelle de
bookassa était-il peut-être celui des
émissaires dépêchés par le gouvernement
français pour tenter de formuler au
souverain en fuite la proposition de tel
ou tel point de chute il n'empêche que
le spectacle grotesque de cette
Caravelle arrêté en bout de piste sur
une base militaire française a eu au
moins le mérite de procurer aux
habitants de cette région un but de
promenade
dominicale c'est toujours la même chose
chaud il y a des journalistes
partout je vois pas désolé vous êtes un
peu déçu non j' V voir oui ça parti du
spectacle B on attend que le l'avion
départ quoi démarre une fois qu'il aura
démarré je sais pas hier on voyait mieux
aujourd'hui on voit les cars et tout ça
c'est plus caché qu'est-ce que vous
attendez en fait qu'est-ce que vous
espérez
voir manière de rendre une petite visite
à qui à bcassa ou à la base
aérienne la base aérienne vous êtes un
voisin de hvreux ouou 45
km ce qui demeure ce soir c'est sur
cette base
d'Évreux cette parcelle de territoire
centrafricain à travers cet avion à
laquelle se cramponne comme à une ultime
bouée le pitoyable souverain sans
couronne qui a son corps défendant a au
moins ce soir un point commun avec une
vedette l'ou milav la saova cette
danseuse étoile desballée du bolchoy qui
est restée bloquée pendant 3 jours et 3
nuits voici quelques semaines sur
l'aéroport Kennedy de New York évre
faauville Jacques colollet TF1 et
j'apprends qu'il y a du nouveau à
l'instant à Évreux il y en effet une
demi-heure environ des voitures du GIGN
du groupement d'intervention de la
gendarmerie nationale sont arrivées sur
la base militaire elles escortaient un/4
de la gendarmerie nationale au vitres
teinté et une grosse voiture une 604 il
semble donc que l'on s'achemine ce soir
vers un dénouement première hypothèse
l'empereur l'ex-empereur BO premier
serait peut-être gardé en résidence
surveillée en France quelque part dans
un lieu qui n'a pas encore été précisé
je vous précise qu'il s'agit simplement
d'une hypothèse et dans ce cas cela
signifierait que les tractations qui ont
commencé il y a 48 Hees maintenant pour
tenter de trouver un pays qui veuille
bien accueillir l'ex- empereur Bokassa
que ces tractation n'est pas abouti 400
personnes ont assisté au comité central
du RPR à Paris un comité central réuni
dans un grand hôtel à hclos ce matin
c'est la Bible économique du RPR en
quelque sorte qui a été présenté par
Jean Méo une priorité le plein emploi un
moyen la relance des investissements
productifs et du commerce extérieur la
plupart des orateurs ont été sévères à
l'égard du gouvernement notamment Michel
Debray et Maurice couv de Murville mais
ce qui est nouveau c'est que la plupart
de ses orateurs se sont livrés à une
autocritique reconnaissant les erreurs
du RPR ces derniers temps et Jacques
Chirac lui-même a reconnu que le RPR
devait désormais corriger le tir Jacques
Lenoir nous avons commis des erreurs je
suis le premier à le reconnaître et je
veux seul en assumer la responsabilité
c'est l'aveu qu'a fait Jacques Chirac
d'emblé dès le début de son intervention
devant le Comité central et de ces
erreurs il a tiré une leçon essentielle
le RPR doit modifier à la fois son
langage ses structures et son
organisation ses méthodes bref ce n'est
pas seulement une autocritique c'est une
véritable mutation en profondeur que
jacirac demande à son mouvement une
mutation dont on connaîtra les modalités
pratiques dès le mois prochain et puis
c'est un nouveau Chirac qui est apparu
au cours de cette intervention aucune
agressivité dans le ton aucune attaque
précise contre le pouvoir mais une
volonté de se situer comme il dit
au-dessus du pays imaginaire qui tient
le haut du pavé à Paris Jacques shirac a
donc lancé un nouvel appel au
rassemblement d'abord au rassemblement
de tous les Gaulistes qu'il invite à la
réconciliation ensuite un appel au
rassemblement du peuple français voilà
une formule qui rappelle bien des
souvenirs rassemblement au-dessus des
partis et qui s'adresse tout
spécialement il l' à la frange la plus
pauvre de la population un appel aux
accent gaulien destiné a-t-il dit à
assurer le redressement du pays pour
Jacques Chirac le changement politique
qui s'impose ne peut pas être obtenu par
la voix parlementaire alors on discerne
mieux maintenant sa nouvelle stratégie à
l'exemple du général de Gaulle qu'il a
souvent cité dans son discours Jacques
Chirac veut apparaître comme l'homme
porteur d'espérance dans le pays voilà
des propos qui ont été très applaudis
par les militants et les parlementaires
et qui sont en liaison direct avec la
prochaine échéance électorale les
présidentielles de 81 à l'issue de cette
journée Claude Labé a tiré les leçons de
ce comité
central après une période de sinance et
de
réflexion notre réunion d'aujourd'hui a
permis d'entendre la voix du
RPR et de constater
effectivement une volonté unanime de
prendre un nouveau départ cette volonté
était surtout exprimée dans le très
grand discours de Jacques Chirac qui
s'est situé à un niveau tel que chacun
comprend aujourd'hui que nous ne situons
pas du tout à la hauteur des querelles
politiciennes mais que nous lançons un
grand appel au rassemblement de tous les
Gaulistes et au-delà d'ailleurs de ces
Gaulistes à l'ensemble des Français et
des Français dans une période où la
situation l'exige tout particulièrement
alors nous avons retrouvé
semble-t-il le souffle des grands
moments et notamment celui qui a présidé
au lancement qui a suivi le lancement du
Rassemblement pour la
République demain s'ouvre à Vitel les
journées parlementaires de l'UDF pendant
4 jours les députés UDF travailleront
sur trois dossiers la politique sociale
la nouvelle politique industrielle et le
budget 79 c'est le premier ministre
monsieur rmond bar qui clôturera ses
journées jeudi prochain quel est l'état
d'esprit des militant UDF pour le savoir
Alain Chaillou s'est rendu dans la
Fédération UDF de lin l'in autrefois
radical socialiste est aujourd'hui un
bon département pour l'UDF deux députés
sur 3 un sénateur sur de plus de 40 %
des maires sont UDF la liste Simon
veille sur l'ensemble du département a
frôé les 35 % le 10 juin dernier dans la
plaine de bour et plus encore sans doute
dans la Cluse du côté de Nantois l'UDF
existe en tout 1500 militants encartés
actifs et mobilisable à tout moment pas
facile les choses étant ce qu'elles sont
de soutenir un gouvernement aussi
critiqué pour un peu comme le dit le
président de la République et comme
beaucoup de Français les militants se
laisserent aller eux aussi au doute à
l'inquiétude et même pourquoi pas au
mécontentement il souhaiteraient sans
doute un premier ministre plus populaire
mais la raison commande et lorsqu'ils
réfléchissent il n'est à leurs yeux pas
d'autres politiques et donc pas d'autres
premier ministres possible que Monsieur
bar c'est l'UDF qui peut le mieux faire
passer la politique sociale que l'on
souhaite parce que nous sommes réalistes
et que nous pensons que certaines choses
à certains moments de de crise
économique peuvent être envisagé et
d'autres doivent être portter la
politique Deb vous paraît la seule
possible ben actuellement oui et si l'on
doit émettre une petite critique je
crois que la petite critique que les
militants prononcent le plus souvent
c'est expliquez-nous plus souvent la
politique car car nous sommes certains
que la France traverse une période
difficile mais il faut nous expliquer le
comment et le pourquoi des décisions le
bureau de l'UDF de lin qui comprend 13
membres se réunit chaque mois toutes les
semaines a lieu une réunion de contact
et d'explication dans chaque canton avec
les militants des militants qui se
répartissent ainsi
sociopressionnellement 40 %
d'agriculteurs 40 % de salariés et 20 %
de profession libérale mais voilà un
militance enans campagne électorale
c'est comme une voiture sans essence
aussi pour 80 année sans échéance or les
responsables départementaux
envisagent-il de multiplier les réunions
les assemblées les séminaires de
formation politique et même la création
d'un journal histoire de garder le moral
de la troupe et de préparer la
réélection de Valérie giscardestin en 81
à laquelle t croi dur comme faire une
chose est sûre tous les militants que
j'ai rencontré sur le terrain se disent
ouvertement favorable à terme à une
fusion des composantes de l'UDF après
les fiançailles le mariage paraît
inévitable mich n'exclut pas une
augmentation des impôts européens le
parlementaire européen élu sur la liste
de Madame Simon veille l'a confié à RTL
le budget de la Communauté européenne
est à la limite de ces possibilités
a-t-il dit et il faudra donc trouver de
nouvelles recettes c'est dans un mois
jour pour jour le 23 octobre que les
médecins déclencheront une grève
nationale d'au moins 24 heures les
services de garde et d'urgenenceces
étant cependant assurés ce mouvement a
été décidé par la Confédération des
syndicats médicaux qui est majoritaire
parmi les médecins libéraux une majorité
de médecin refuse en effet les projets
de réforme du gouvernement sur la
sécurité sociale c'est un événement sans
précédent sur lequel s'explique
maintenant le président de la
Confédération des syndicats
médicaux par cette décision parce que ce
qui compte pour le médecin c'est d'avoir
la liberté de prescription car c'est
vraiment la liberté fondamentale pour
les malades liberté de prescrire aussi
bien ce qui est nécessaire pour une
investigation pour connaître votre
maladie que pour vous donner les
médicaments thérapeutique dont vous avez
besoin or le gouvernement vient de
décider de façon active et à mon avis
insuffisamment réfléchi par ce qu'on
appelle une enveloppe globale c'està
qu'on déterminerait chaque année une
enveloppe qui obligerait les médecins à
un choix impossible à savoir si vous
prescrivez moins on augmentera vos
honoraires ou le financement de vos
entreprise et si vous préscrivez trop
bien vos honoraires sert bloqués
autrement dit on oppose les intérêts de
chaque médecin l'intérêt de du malade
qui vient le consulter c'est vraiment
une solution impossible et que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter c'est contraire à
notre mission al je précise tout de
suite que grève ça veut pas dire que la
population sera laissée sans soin les
services de garde sont
assurés sauf événement nouveau donc la
grève nationale des Médecins en France
aura lieu le 23 octobre avec possibilité
de prolongation Monseigneur Le Fèvre
fêtait aujourd'hui son c'est-à-dire ces
50 ans de sacerdoce 15000 personnes
environ venues de France mais aussi
d'Allemagne des États-Unis se sont
retrouvé à la porte de versaill
commentant la cérémonie le président de
la communion épiscopale de l'opinion
publique monsieur Badr Monseigneur Badr
a déclaré ce chiffre de 15000 était bien
peu de choses comparé aux millions de
catholiques qui dans toute l'Europe ont
assisté aujourd'hui à la messe tel que
le souhaite le concile Bernard
chevalier pour fêter ces 50 ans de
cerdos Monseigneur Lefèvre a donc choisi
à la demande de ses amis le Hall des
Expositions de la Porte de Versailles
applaudi par la bonne dizaine de
milliers de fidèle à l'entrée à la
sortie de l'Office le prélat a invité
son auditoire à une triple croisade
celle des jeunes des familles et des
chefs de famille en vue d'un
rétablissement d'une civilisation
chrétienne en France il nous faut a-t-il
précisé des maires catholiques des
députés catholiques c'est cela la bonne
politique il a insisté sur la nécessité
de s'en tenir à la messe de toujours en
précisant que les ennemis de l'Église en
Pologne notamment persécutaient ceux qui
lui étaient fidèles une occasion aussi
pour le supérieur du séminaire descôes
de rappeler que toute action chrétienne
avait son origine dans l'Eucharistie un
office en latin avec la chorale de sa
Nicolas un sonnet de Monseigneur
ducobourgetis à la gloire de l'évêque
qui a des ennuis avec le Vatican et une
assistance unanime pour chanter sa foi
avec les fastes d'une liturgie remise à
l'honneur Monseigneur Le Fèvre n' cité
qu'une fois le pape et quand nous lui
avons demandé ce qu'il pensait de la
prise de position des évêques français
qui ont qualifié cette messe de
provocation et de défi lancé à l'église
unie au pape il s'est contenté de cette
réponse je n'y ai pas répondu j'aurais
pu faire une allusion j'aurais pu mais
je ne préfère pas je trouve que tout
cela ça ne fait qu'en venimer les les
relations c'est absolument ridicule de
parler d'un défi alors que pour le jour
de mes 50 ans de sacerdoce c'est pas de
ma faute si j'ai 50 ans de sacerdoce
j'en peux rien moi
il y a eu plusieurs manifestations de
motards ce weekend notamment à Nancy à
Paris où les motards ont bruillamment
défilé sur leurs engins pour protester
contre le projet d'instauration d'une
vignette sur les plus de 500 cm C et
j'apprends que ce soir il y a moins
d'une heure 400 motards environ bloque
depuis donc 19h15 le péage de
coutevrultl en Scine et mararne
c'est-à-dire sur l'autoroute A4 dans le
sens province-pis ce qui doit provoquer
d'énormes embouteillages en raison des
retours du weekend Monsieur Christian
Bonet ministre de l'Intérieur s'est
rendu ce matin au chevet des policiers
blessés lors de la manifestation de
protestation contre l'assassinat de
Pierre Goldman Monsieur Christian Bonnet
a rendu hommage au sang-froid des forces
de police et a condamné les récents
attentats le ministre de l'Intérieur a
rappelé que face aux provocations d'où
qu'elles viennent face aux agitateurs
quels qu'ils soitt- il dit face aux
terroristes de tout bord les forces de
police font et feront leur devoir sans
défaillance
la mort du président maotsetung marque
décidément un tournant dans l'histoire
de la Chine populaire le gouvernement de
monsieur wakofeng a condamné à plusieurs
reprises les excès de la Révolution
culturelle mais cette fois c'est un
tournant dans la politique étrangère de
Pékin qui se manifeste à travers la
déclaration d'une délégation chinoise à
Moscou le chef de cette délégation a
exprimé aujourd'hui dans la capitale
d'Union soviétique le désir ardent du
peuple chinois d'améliorer les relations
d'état à état avec les Soviétiques cette
déclaration a même été remise à la
presse par les Chinois eux-mêmes ce qui
indique l'importance qui attache Pékin
mais à Pékin le chinois de la rue est
davantage préoccupé par les rencontres
sportives que par la nouvelle politique
étrangère à l'égal à l'égard de l'Union
soviétique c'est ce qu'a constaté notre
envoyé spécial en Chine populaire Gérard
Saint-Paul les chinois sont surtout
occupés à l'ouverture de leurs jeux
nationaux sortes d'olympiad à l'échelle
du pays qui ont commencé c'est hier ou
encore à la promenade habituelle place
Tienanmen l'atmosphère ici est toujours
hyper active mais pacifique mais surtout
le président wakofeng prépare déjà son
voyage en Europe qui à partir du 14
octobre prochain le conduira en France
en Allemagne fédérale en Grande-Bretagne
et en Italie les dirigeants chinois
attendent beaucoup de cette visite sur
le plan industriel économique en général
mais aussi sans doute politique pour
contrebalancer la puissance soviétique
au centre de l'Europe avec l'URSS
précisément on ne se cache pas de dire
en privé que des négociations peuvent
être longues qu'elles prendront
peut-être 4 5 ans mais apparemment on
n'est pas décidé à claquer la porte
l'Union soviétique aimerait bien au fond
obtenir un accord de coopération envoyer
à nouveau des experts en Chine pourquoi
pas c'est un lointain projet à cela il y
aurait des conditions chinoises
premièrement queland onne plus ou moins
le Vietnam deuxièmement que les troupes
soviétiques reculent loin derrière la
frontière entre la Chine et le RSS
troièmement qu'elles évacuent la
Mongolie autant de conditions
draconiennes mais qui signifie qu'une
longue marche d'usure a commencé en
espérant de la part des Chinois que le
Vietnam dans le Sud-Est asiatique se
fatiguera le premier notamment au
Cambodge mais tout cela pour l'instant
en Chine c'est du très long terme ce
sont des perspectives qui ne sont pas
pour pour demain ni peut-être même pour
après-demain en attendant les dirigeants
chinois maintiennent le cap de
l'ouverture mesurée à l'ouest et
notamment en direction de la France on
constate ici quotidiennement que la
coopération sino française est toujours
aussi souhaité que les chinois sont
toujours aussi demandeurs c'est donc
l'actualité du voyage du président
wakfeng une actualité que l'on prépare
ici très activement pour un enjeu à la
fois économique et je vous le disais
aussi diplomatique qui sera capitale ici
TF1
Pékin je vous rappelle que les 3 4 et 5
octobre prochain TF TF1 vous présentera
en direct de Pékin les journaux
télévisés de 13h d'Iv mourouszi une
opération exceptionnelle et prestigieuse
que chacun d'entre nous aura à cœur de
suivre voir vivre la Chine en direct sur
notre écran de télévision c'est tout de
même un grand moment dans l'histoire des
relations internationales la Chine
s'ouvre sans davantage au monde
occidental que de chemin parcourus
depuis 1971 cette année-là Henry
Kissinger s'était rendu secrètement en
Chine pour préparer la rencontre
historique entre Richard Nixon et maoung
c'est ce qu'enry Kissinger raconte en
exclusivité dans l'Express qui paraît
demain l'éminence grise du président
Nixon il fait une révélation sa première
rencontre avec de Gaulle en février 69
pomidou aux Assor et le voyage du
président français aux États-Unis ré le
livre d'enri Kissinger couvre la période
qui va de 68 à 73 le tout toutpuissant
patron de la diplomatie américaine nous
invite à le suivre et avec quel talent
dans les coulisses de l'événement avec
un grand E il brosse des portrait
souvent savoureux des grands et des
moins grands de ce monde disons-le tout
de suite il porte une réelle admiration
au dirigeant français et d'abord au
général de Gaulle personnage
extraordinaire dit-il et il a cette
phrase on avait l'impression que s'il se
dirigeait vers une fenêtre le centre de
la pièce se déplacerait et tout le monde
basculerait moins connu peut-être est
l'admiration qu'il a pour Georg ponfidou
pour pour son intelligence sa dignité sa
force de caractère l'un des seuls hommes
d'État avec lesquels on avait plaisir à
discuter de sujets non politiques comme
beaucoup de Français ajoutent Kissinger
il avait la conviction que rien de bon
ne pouvait venir des États-Unis pourtant
c'est grâce à lui que les relations
franco-américaines se sont amélioré et
il donne ce coup de chapeau à la
politique étrangère de la France souvent
épineuse elle a toujours été sérieuse et
cohérente sous Georges Pompidou et plus
tard sous son brillant et compétent
successeur Valérie giscardestin puis
vient le récit de son premier voyage
secret en Chine il expose les véritables
ruses de siu auxquels il devra recourir
pour que le mystère reste intact
officiellement il est au Pakistan et il
raconte commment on l'affuble d'un
chapeau et de lunettes noir à Pékin on
lui fait traverser la capitale chinoise
dans une limousine au rideau tiré là il
découvre quelqu'un qui restera comme
l'un des deux ou trois hommes les plus
impressionnants qu'il ait jamais
rencontré Chuen l il le crédite d'une
bonne part de la réussite du
spectaculaire rapprochement entre les
deux ennemis d'hierier qui va combler un
gouffre de 20 ans d'ignorance ils ont au
total 17 he de conversation Richard
Nixon peut aller en Chine il y sera en
février 72 Richard Nixon Henry Kissinger
traite longuement de ses rapports avec
le président des États-Unis on comprend
qu'ils sont plus complices qu'amille
Nixon ne s'intéresse guerre à l'économie
il n'est pas très au fait des dossiers
militaires il n'est pas très brillant en
politique intérieure mais mais il va au
cœur du problème en politique étrangère
rien n'est plus faux dit Kissinger que
l'idée d'un Nixon président impérial
aboyant des ordres à ses subordonnés
dompté au contraire ce solitaire ce
tortueux ce torturé je cite bien sûr
convoque son collaborateur quatre fois
dans la même journée pour se faire
répéter qu'il a bien été à la hauteur
Richard Nixon n'a pas d'humour mais
Henry Kissinger en a pour deux le livre
est riche en détail souvent fort drôle
Henry Kissinger mêle avec le plus grand
bonheur l'analyse et l'anecdote l'ancien
professeur devenu super diplomate n'est
jamais rébarbatif ce livre danse plus de
1500 pages se lit comme un roman du
nouveau dans l'affaire de l'ex-empereur
bokasa toujours dans sa caravelle à
Évreux une caravelle qui je vous le
rappelle est maintenant entourée par des
voitures du GN du groupement
d'intervention de la gendarmerie
nationale avec une 604 et un/4 de la
gendarmerie aux vitres teinté il semble
donc qu'une évacuation de l'avion soit
imminente j'apprends en effet un à
l'instant par un télégramme qui me vient
de République centra-fricaine que le
nouveau chef de l'État centraafricain le
prés président David daakco a annoncé
son intention de lancer un mandat
d'arrêt international contre
l'exempereur bocassa mais cela posera
tout de même un problème juridique car
même si la République centra-fricaine
lance un mandat d'arrêt international
comme l'ex-emperur bookassa la
nationalité française en principe et
juridiquement la France ne peut pas
extrader l'un de ses ressortissants
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme certains
juriste il y aura là sans doute une
bataille qui mérite d'être suivie les
ministres des Finances des pays membres
des pays monétaires européens et les
gouverneurs des banques centrales se
sont réunis secrètement aujourd'hui à
Bruxelles ils ont étudié l'éventualité
d'un réaménagement des parités
monétaires à l'intérieur du système
monétaire européen à la suite de la
forte hausse du Deutsch Mark la monnaie
allemande en Espagne le gouverneur
militaire de la province basque de
guispuscoa a été tué dans un attentat en
fin de matinée tous les postes
frontières avec la France ont été fermés
de nombreux barrages de police ont été
dressés dans cette province espagnole
pour tenter de retrouver les terroristes
le gouverneur militaire avait refusé à
plusieurs reprises toute protection
policière depuis le début de l'année en
Espagne 109 personnes ont trouvé la mort
dans des actions terroristes dont 45
policiers et 12
[Musique]
militaires avec Daniel Pora la page
sportive de ce journal et il faut bien
le constater Daniel cette fin de semaine
a été plutôt profitable aux Français oui
cinq records de France de natation ont
été battus dans celui du 100 m au jeu
méditerranéen un split où les athlètes
français font une ample provision de
médaille la dernière cet après-midi avec
GUID Delvin en judo Patrick ponce vient
d'être sacré cet après-midi champion du
monde de motocycliste en 700 cm C sur le
circuit d'okenheim en Allemagne et puis
Bernardino 1979 a mis 3 minutes de moins
qu'Ino 78 pour remporter à Cannes son 3e
Grand Prix des nations sur 90 km avec 1
minute 45 secondes d'avance sur Mozer et
plus de 3 minutes sur zutomelk et
schreuten Ino passe en tête du Trophée
Super Prestige qui récompense le
meilleur coureur de
l'année Yannick Noa a éliminé George
Goven en demi-finale du National à Nice
en TR manches et Yannick Noa rencontrera
demain en finale Dominique Bedel qui
s'est qualifié lui au dépend de
Jean-Louis aet on est sûr d'avoir un
très jeune champion de France no a 19
ans et Bel qui monte au filet ici
victorieux
et on a un tout jeune champion du monde
de ski nautique Patrice Martin un en
tête 15 ans qui a surclassé tous ses
adversaires au championnat du monde de
Figur à Toronto dont voici les premières
images Patrice un blondinet d' 1,50 et
40 kg que les Canadiens n'appellent plus
que le petit
[Musique]
prince et un petit prince qui a tout
l'avenir devant lui le tirc il fallait
jouer le 4 c'est le 8 c'est-à-dire
checkdum vagari et narablou très vite
checkdum casazak bleu porté par Maurice
Philipp Ron se détache il est vainement
poursuivi par narablou numéro 8 qui va
perdre à la fin la seconde place au
profit de vagaries longtemps en tête
grand Mogo et 4e devant xerval venu de
loin 4 ass 8 un tirc qui rapporte dans
l'ordre et pour 5 francs 6364 francs
dans un ordre différent toujours pour 5
francs 1000 7 francs le temps demain des
nuages sur presque toute la France mais
avec de belles éclaircis notamment dans
le Midi où le mistral et la tramontane
souffleront les températures seront tout
de même généralement en hausse il était
temps car il a fait plutôt froid sur la
France en cette fin septembre
aujourd'hui vers 23h30 le dernier
journal vous sera présenté par Marie
lorogri bonsoir et
merci